I think you'll find this super interesting.
The term gaslighting has become very
tainted by a movement on the right to claim
that the use of the term gaslighting is in
and of itself some kind of ruse. Now, the truth
is that gaslighting is a real thing. Sometimes
the word is applied correctly and sometimes it
isn't. But generally speaking, gaslighting is
a form of psychological manipulation in which a
person or a group covertly sows seeds of doubt
in a targeted individual or group, making them
question their own memory, perception or judgment.
So simply lying about something, telling a
lie, it doesn't really rise to the level of
being gaslighting in spirit or even by the letter
of what it is, there has to be some kind of more
calculated, manipulative intent. And last night
on his Fox News program, host Tucker Carlson
casually claimed that he and his team weren't
able to find any evidence that Cunanan and Q
even existed or that they have a following or
that they're a thing. And part of the reason
he says that he doesn't believe they exist is
that he didn't find an official Kuhnen website,
which, of course, if you know anything
about Kuhnen, you would understand. Well,
they don't have a website if you haven't
if somehow you're not aware of Kuhnen,
I envy you. Kuhnen is a disproven right wing
conspiracy theory which claims that there's a
secret cabal of Satan worshiping pedophiles
running a global child sex trafficking ring
and that they plotted against Donald Trump.
Sometimes Hillary is involved, sometimes not,
and that Donald Trump was sent to be
president to root out these horrible people.
Supporters of Kuhnen include white nationalists
and other far right extremists, and, of course,
they were major supporters of Donald Trump
and they were big players in continuing to sow
the false stories of so-called
voter fraud and election fraud
in the time after the 2020 presidential election.
Now, the people who believe in this stuff and
support Trump through it definitely exist. They're
obviously wrong on the facts. But Tucker here says
we can't find any evidence that
this is even a thing. And this
is a perfect example of gaslighting.
Let's take a look at the video
so it's worth finding out where the public
is getting all this false information. That's
disinformation, as we'll call it. So we checked we
spent all day trying to locate the famous Kuhnen,
which in the end we learned is not even a
website. If it's out there, we could not find it.
Then we checked Marjorie Taylor Green's Twitter
feed because we have heard she traffics in
disinformation, CNN told us, but nothing there.
So Tucker learned that Kuhnen doesn't have a
website. Well, we knew that he says he couldn't
find Kuhnen, nor any evidence of disinformation
posted by Marjorie Taylor Green ever. This
is truly gaslighting. First of all, you know,
the whole idea of Q from the beginning was they
don't have a website. There's no Kuhnen Gazette,
there is no Q Report equivalent of the Drudge
Report where they post their ideas and articles.
The whole concept was this is a here's a
term, this is a sub rosa thing where there's
supposedly an insider providing the information,
posting it to obscure Internet forums and it's
repeated or signal boosted by the followers
of. Q So this is a red herring and it is
gaslighting. Tucker, not finding a website isn't
evidence for or against anything. Now, mind you,
Tucker is the same guy who says he mailed physical
flash drives without having backed up the content
across the country during his so-called
investigation of Hunter Biden. So he's not
necessarily the brightest guy when it comes to
these investigations and informational security.
But OK, now the extra gaslighting is Tucker and
Fox News have actually been major amplifiers
themselves of election related disinformation,
which plays right into the entire Q perspective.
And they're being sued at this point for
it for repeating some of the same claims
coming from the kuhnen wing of the Republican
Party, including that Donald Trump actually won
the twenty twenty election. Now, in terms of,
you know, the Marjorie Taylor Green thing,
he says, we looked at Marjorie Taylor Green's
Twitter. We didn't find any disinformation ever.
That's a laughable joke. And she's promoted cute
stuff for a very long time. But you don't need
to go back very far. Just look at the stuff she's
posted over the last 24 to 36 hours. This morning,
Marjorie Taylor Green tweeted, quote, Democrats
are so beholden to the abortion murder lobby
and their blood money campaign contributions that
they nominate a guy, Basara, for Health and Human
Services, who's fine with murdering babies up
until the day they are born and maybe even after.
That's not disinformation. Come on. And then
also spreading disinformation about January 6th
itself, tweeting Speaker Pelosi. Have you
figured out who planted the pipe bombs at
the RNC and the DNC on January 5th, the night
before the Capitol attack on January six,
showing the attack was planned and not incited
by incited by President Trump and directed at
both Republicans and Democrats? That's just the
last 24 to 36 hours. And she's been spreading and
repeating Kuhnen stuff for month after month after
month. This is gaslighting. What Tucker Carlson
did is gaslighting, making his viewers question
their reality. Maybe Kuhnen doesn't even exist,
in which case, by the way, it would make
everything that Democrats are saying a lie,
which is exactly the idea that populist Tucker
Carlson wants to promulgate on his program.
That's gaslighting.
And unfortunately,
you have a really willing audience, a
really eager audience to follow whatever
Tucker Carlson says on his program. Remember
Tucker Carlson's lawyers, Fox News lawyers used
when defending Tucker Carlson in lawsuits they
used as a defense? Tucker Carlson shouldn't be
interpreted as telling the truth. He's doing
hyperbole and he's doing entertainment. He's not
actually reporting facts on his program. That's
what lawyers said under oath, not under oath.
The lawyers aren't under oath in court proceedings
defending the statements of Tucker Carlson. Just
remember that when you watch this program,
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.